and finally new rule if you're one of
the millions of Americans who wore green
to work today and started celebrating
st. Patrick's Day at lunchtime stop put
down the green beer take off the [ __ ] me
I'm kiss paste t-shirt and hear me out
because as an Irish American I must say
the association of my tribe with this
drunken slob fest is getting a little
old
been there puked that I mean imagine if
we celebrated other ethnic groups in the
same way we do the Irish on st. Patty's
Day we're the worst stereotype is
reinforced what if we're Columbus Day
everyone wore wifebeaters and move back
in with their mother what if during
Black History Month we all bought
Lobster with food stand
what is for Cinco DeMayo we all went
swimming in blue jeans or for Rosh
Hashanah we all went out for Chinese and
then argued about the bill for an hour
[Applause]
what if a Chinese New Year wheel we all
made soup out of endangered species and
then got in our cars and drove like [ __ ]
folks when my great great parents
great-grandparents arrived in New York
from Ireland they were greeted with
signs and shop windows that read no
Irish need apply no one would hire the
Irish people which is why they had to
form Riverdance and and all the things
said about Muslim immigrants in America
today were said about the Irish then
they have funny accents they eat weird
food they have an odd religion of course
in their case it's all true and that
brings us to some interesting questions
like why the Liberals treat some
minorities as protected species but not
all why grown at that when a minute ago
we were so freely laughing at the Asian
driver joke and is there anything wrong
if you are part of a particular culture
to feel an extra not guilt but
collective responsibility even if you
yourself didn't do something bad
liberals certainly feel that way about
reparations on for reparations and I
personally never owned slaves check my
taxes I mean it's been a long time since
anyone in America held blacks in unpaid
servitude if you don't count college
sports
if you're under 30 you might not
remember but in the 70s and 80s
terrorism wasn't a Muslim thing it was
an Irish thing back then the bombs were
going off in Belfast not Baghdad and the
Virgin's you met in heaven were named
Kevin and Sean
[Applause]
and it's not hard to imagine a scenario
where the Irish terrorists of that era
tried to get America involved in their
war by striking here where they had a
lot of financial support from Irish
Americans and then Irish Americans like
me might have been the ones facing
extreme betting what would my reaction
have been I can't say for sure but I
don't think it would have been how dare
you even suspect me because I know why
they were suspecting me as long as it
wasn't a witch-hunt my response would
have been these are my people
I should own this a little more than the
non Irish guy and I think there are a
lot of Muslims today who feel exactly
that way but their voices are drowned
out by liberals screaming Islamophobe
you know there was a draw the Prophet
contest in Garland Texas a few years ago
provocative yes but you either believe
in free speech or you don't this is
America we're supposed
[Applause]
unfortunately a couple of Muslims didn't
and attacked and when they got shot a
local Muslim resident named Mohammed jet
Puri said the extremists got what's
coming to them you don't just shoot
people I'm glad they got killed see he
may be Muslim but he's a real Texan and
any Muslim American I ever talked to
basically totally the same thing every
immigrant said that they're glad they
left the old country behind and came to
a place that's better freer let's
beholden to traditions
I saw meme going around the internet
last week when it was international
Woman's Day and it said a woman should
be whatever the [ __ ] she wants so
liberals you can applaud that or you can
pretend this is just a fashion trend you
just can't do both